This hammer here is a fantastic
tool to build stuff.
But in order for it to work, it needs
my immediate attention of energy.
I can't just turn it on and
let it do its thing.
In today's affordable tool shed,
we've only recently got a few
additions that are different.
These modern high end
tools like this 3D print-
>> [COUGH] We don't have the budget
for that.
>> Right.
Modern tools like our 3D printer,
that's out for maintenance,
can be given a task that it then
performs autonomously until it's done.
In today's life of a web developer,
we're seeing a similar trend,
a large collection of tools that you
feed tasks and that then automate and
improve many aspects of your workflow.
Let's dive into
the world of build tools.